time dilation is one of the inherent
qualities in relativity that
where you have gravitation
there's a warp in time
that
your time relative to a frame of
reference to another
another place where you have less of a
gravitational attraction or less mass
that you're the time is going to be
moving more slowly
well that seems like the basis for
some sort of time management that you
could use
gravity
to manage time by way of time dilation
where where you had more gravity
and where others had less gravity your
time would be moving more slowly
relative to them and so i decided that i
would try to
market this
and i did so by
creating time ingots it seemed logical
enough i i founded a company called
spacetime industries and
the time ingots were as you can see
well there were bars of lead that i
bought on ebay and i packaged them
though and the thing about this
technology is that you could very
conveniently put one of these on your
desk and you would have as your frame of
reference
ever so slight an advantage over the
person in the next cubicle so
granted we're talking about a a very
very small advantage but then i realized
that there were many other ways in which
to
use this sort of advantage that came
courtesy of gravity and
of mr einstein namely you could have
what i came to call the time warp
undershirt a time warp undershirt puts
greater
density more mass
around your heart
relative to the rest of your body
especially your brain and as a result
you end up with this very slight
advantage of living just that little bit
longer
relative to
how long you think you're living or you
get to think a little bit faster
relative to how long you're living
i will grant you that this is a minimal
effect we're talking about perhaps a
billionth of a billionth of maybe a
billionth of a second over the course of
the entire length of time that the
universe has been here so
you really
need in order to be able to feel this
and to take advantage of this in a
serious way you need well you need a
neutron star so
that's what i came up with as
a way to move forward in this technology
namely i came up with a sort of an
architecture that could be built on
neutron stars um what i called an
elevator house and the concept of the
elevator house was basically that every
room was on a shaft and you could
arrange your life by the way that you
arranged the rooms on these different
shafts so as to be able to fully manage
your time and of course up on the roof
is the garden where plants are growing
relatively quickly compared to your life
and you're able therefore to have
strawberries
as many as you want whenever you want
them
but
this is all still sort of selfish and
still sort of
not
fully managing time to the full
potential i don't believe i think that
where it gets interesting
is where it gets communal that is to say
not to manage time just for yourself but
what if an entire community
had time management in this
relativistic way well i decided to
design some cities i decided to go into
urban planning why not i'm an
experimental philosopher after all and
so what i did was i designed a few
cities now
for my cities what i did was i used the
equivalence of velocity to mass because
it was easier at least it was easier to
make some blueprints and so i ended up
with cities like this
the cities have different districts that
are spinning very very fast but at
different rates relative to each other
those of you who uh no clock making are
able probably to figure out that what's
going on right here is that the
residential district is spinning at a
rate that is going to give you a
relatively long life span compared to
those are trees that's the agricultural
district on the other side so you get to
eat well and in the middle is the
industrial district which frankly we
do need our
iphones and other plastic things but not
too many of them so it seemed like it
really belonged in the middle and so i
then went ahead and i came up with some
other
uh cities that could also be built along
these lines and submitted these
out in the world totally open source for
any
government that wished to take it on and
to build one of these
nobody's done it yet i
have to tell you but it is also
interesting to me that
it got
quite a lot of attention that for
instance arkatizer one of the
architectural trade publications wrote
it up and not only them but also the
wall street journal
and this is interesting to me i mean not
only is it an
excuse for me to boast it also is
interesting from the standpoint of what
i was talking about earlier namely how
to do philosophy in public in a way that
engages people in a broad conversation
where
what it's about kind of comes out of the
conversation itself and so that you end
up with in the case of a project like
this all sorts of things falling out of
it all sorts of ideas that i certainly
didn't have going into it and i probably
ended up stealing from other people as i
was having conversations with them but
really in terms of how we think about
time
in our society and the way in which
the arrangement of time and the
understanding of time in communal terms
fundamentally changes time as
experienced and how society can be built
in ways perhaps not using
quite the same amount of elaborate
clockwork as i've done but in ways that
might be truer to the
relationship that we have through time
[Music]
you